on va on va voir le sondage dans un
instant j' l'attends avec impatience euh
le résultat euh mais je voudrais je
voudrais des oui et des non pour vous
donc c'est oui pour vous Daniel c'est
oui mais vous allez vraiment en
discothèque non j'y vais pas non mais en
fait la différence entre Gill enfin tous
ceux qui disent NON et Yar c'est que eux
ils sont dans l'idéologie vous vous êtes
dans la réalité j'avais parlé
quelquefois de du Far West je pense que
vous vous vivez des scèesinges du FAR
wouest il y avvez les affiches sur dans
les rues des western je trouve que vous
avez 100 fois raison ils sont s fois
nois c'est c'est illégal mais vous allez
peut-être faire avancer les choses en
faisant des actions comme ça vous rendez
service à tout le monde vous rendez
service à ceux qui peuvent croiser les
délinquants qui sont des gens dangereux
vous rendez service à la police ça peut
aider donc moi je suis à 100 % avec vous
et surtout je n'aime pas du tout le
procédé des amis de Gilles et que tu as
bien bien bien calqué c'est-à-dire que
dès que quelqu'un veut de l'ordre il est
d'extrême droite excuse-moi monsieur
veut de l'ordre il est en plein les
mains dans le campoui et et c'est facile
du coup on donne des petites phrases on
s'èime le doute et comme ça monsieur que
regard les vidéos qui regardais beaucoup
de vidéos exactement et je trouve
monsieur très mesuré et dans la réalité
je suis désolé il a les mains dans le
cambouille excusez-moi mais voilà c'est
on s'est voilé la face trop longtemps et
maintenant à force de de rien dire de
pas dire cette petite phrase parce que
peut-être elle peut être mal prise on en
est où on en est aujourd'hui encore une
fois moi je valide pleinement le procédé
qu'il soit légal ou pas c'est une arme
dissuisive ça permet à au aux personnes
qu'on affiche de ne plus revenir et ça
crée tout de même un sentiment de honte
et c'est l'objectif par contre il y a
une question dans ce pays on on emmerde
souvent les on emmerde souvent les
agresser et non les agresseurs est-ce
que il y en a qui ont déjà porté plainte
ou pas encore puisque vous les avez
affiché est-ce que vous avez peur de la
réponse judiciaire à venir ça peut
arriver je l'ai je l'ai dit il y a pas
très longtemps 100 % des gens que j'ai
affiché ont pris contact avec moi en
moins de 24 heures pour s'excuser alors
pour s'excuser pour trouver le moyen de
sortir de cette situation parce que ça
réellement ça leur pourrit la vie ça
c'est vrai le pourrit la vie et encore
hier on m'a appelé sur une de mes
dernière vidéo en disant je suis allé à
à ma boulangerie euh le boulanger m'a
demandé si j'allais enfin je vais pas
donner les détails mais être violent
dans la dans dans dans la boulangerie
c'est terrible je sais mais ce gars-là
on av avait ni son nom ni son prénom je
l'ai eu je l'ai eu voilà et on vous
menace pas jamais c'est 30 ans de ma vie
des menaces je ça me fait absolument
rien je me balade n'importe où dans Renn
contrairement à ce que Gill dit le
magrbin me serent la main il me prennent
en photo avec eux enfin bon et et tant
mieux les maghrébains qui se tiennent
bien je les adore les blancs qui se
tiennent bien je les adore parce qu'en
fait il a dit qu'il parla
coach j'ai tout le monde en fait quoi
c'est incroyable oui g et Géraldine là
vous râz le fait d'afficher les
délinquants quand hier on a montré la
vidéo de la jeune fille qui s'est fait
agresser dans le lycée si S avit pas eu
cette vidéo qu'on avait pas montré
peut-être que les choses n'auraient pas
bougé c'est ça aussi qui fait bouger les
choses c'est d'afficher les délincant
est-ce que voulez est-ce vous voulez que
je vous montre le sondage pour vous
calmer un peu
gagn Raon
t vous et bravo à vous parce que
regardez le sondage il est écrasant 93
94% des gens et moi je suis d'accord à
fond il faut afficher des délinquant sur
les réseaux
sociauxi je vous le dis voilà moi pour
moi pour moi c'est une très bonne
solution et je suis persuadé parce que
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes très
sympathique ici he franchement vous êtes
très sympathique mais pour moi vous avez
jamais pris une décision excusez-moi je
ai jamais vu prendre une décision donc
vous êtes très sympathique vous regardez
les autres vous dites tiens bah lui il
est dans la merde lui il est dans la
merde lui il est dans la merde et ils
peuvent rien faire à un moment
aujourd'hui les
commerçants les patrons discothèque les
restaurateurs ils doivent prendre des
décisions seuls parce qu'aujourd'hui
personne ne les aide sachez-le just
voilà donc aujourd'hui les mecs il se
retrouvent face à des situations qui
sont très compliquées et aujourd'hui et
ben ils trouvent des solutions comme ils
peuvent donc là il y a dernière fois on
a eu ce commerçant qui a mis la la photo
de ces voleurs
voilà
no pas question on parle pas de ça là la
question c'est il affiche les
délinquants sur les réseaux sociaux
a-t-il raison la réponse des
téléspectateurs elle est à cette
question d'accord Géraldine ma c'est pas
est-ce qu'on doit faire doit se faire
vacciner ou pas la question c'est
afficher les délinquants sur les réseaux
sociaux a-t-il raison oui à 94 % la
question elle est là la réponse elle est
là tout ça
je dis aujourd'ui quand on a ce monsieur
qui a mis la photo de ses voleurs c'est
parce qu'il en peut plus aujourd'hui il
peut pas s'en sortir déjà un commerce
très
compliqué
par
person la centèle ne vient plus derrière
des BAGAR dans la discèque les me qui
disent et on peut pas y aller on a peur
d'aller bien sûr non mais là j'ai raison
Valé mais n'importe quoi bagarss unu là
arrête laisse-moi parler parce que ça
fatig qu quand tu commences à êre comme
parce que c'est unjusticier il a 15 mecs
derrière lui c'est un patron boî de nuit
il a 15 gardes du corps vous êtes en
train de dire aux gens allez-y montrer
des vidéos quand les gens ils vont se
faire marbrer vous allez voir l'exemple
qu'il donne lui c'est facile il fait du
MMA il fait du ceci il y a une justice
mais non mais y a des vidéos s'il y a
des bagarres il appelle la police la
police vient c'est pas la police lui que
c'est la police pour taper les gens bal
mais mais c'est pas de ça qu'on parle
c'est pas de ça qu'on parle on te parle
des gens qu'on a balancé sur les réseaux
parce que écoute-moi mais écoute-moi
écoute-moi si et si derrière il a trouvé
la seule solution qui fait que les gens
puissent revenir dans sa discothèque
s'il y a des bagarres tout le temps dans
une discothèque personne va revenir
c'est très simple et la clientèle va se
barrer c'est tout simplement ça c'est ça
même même valériie d'accord avec moi
làus là-dessus évidemment il y a un
préjudice si si la discothèque on
considère qu'elle est malfamée
évidemment il perdra de la clientèle moi
je peux vous poser une question monsieur
sur justement afficher les délinquants
sur les réseaux est-ce que l'alternative
d'afficher les délinquants entre
guillemets mais pas sur les réseaux
c'est-à-dire donc puisque vous avez en
votre possession les vidéos de les
envoyer au procureur de la République
par exemple dans dans l'exemple que vous
venez de de donner cette histoire où ça
devait être fermé le l'histoire close
hop il dégageer si vous envoyez au
procureur il va réouvrir le dossier donc
pourquoi le mettre sur le réseau ce sont
les délais souvent qui sont beaucoup
plus longs entre les victimes et la
réelle justice et les gens quand quand
ils nous appellent pour dire je vais
redonner un autre cas de figure pour
répondre à cette question et 2 minutes
ouais en même en 30 secondes euh il y a
là il y a quelques mois on a une fille
qui a failli se faire embarquer par
trois individus d'accord ils l'ont
attrapé ils ont essayé de l'emmener dans
la voiture on l'a vu au loin à 80 m de
la porte de l'établissement on a couru
on a réussi à la sauver d'accord non
sans mal mais on a réussi à récupérer la
demoiselle on l'a ramené c'était la
fille d'une
gendarme on a réussi avec les caméras
que j'ai sur moi alors oui euh ok on
arrive on est nombreux on est 10 oui bah
comme eux euh Raymon comme eux en fait
ils sont 15 ils sont 20 ils sont 25 euh
je suis pas évidemment le Yar c'est un
chef de guerre il va pas tout seul pour
gagner une guerre il va pas tout seul
dites pas aux gens qu'il faut filmer
mais mais mais non mais je finis
vraiment je finis et là le le j'ai des
vidéos évidemment il y a une procédure
judiciaire qui se lance et on est
incapable de retrouver les individus moi
j'ai la vidéo je vois la tête la police
me dit on sait pas qui sont on les
connaî pas ok d'accord je poste la vidéo
ce sont les gens qui m'ont dit où on
pouvait les trouver ce sont les gens qui
ont vu la vidéo qu'on dit on les a vu à
tel bar on les a vu à tel dans la telle
rue on sait qu' traînent dans tel
endroit et on a fini par les trouver
grâce à ça en fait ce sont les gens qui
ont dit où on pouvait les avoir comment
je fais ça c'est pas le procureur qui va
mettre les vidéos en ligne sur la vidéo
surveillance je suis d'accord sur les
les affaires criminelle ou la ville elle
filme je suis d'accord sur les histoires
comme la la grand-mère qu'on a frappé ou
l'étudiante je suis d'accord sur un cas
d'enlèvement je suis d'accord sur un cas
d'enlèvement c'est un enlèvement tu me
racontes un enlèvement bien sûr que je
suis d'accord mais tu là on dit aux gens
quand il y a des délinquants filmez-les
et mettez-les sur les réseaux mais les
gens ils ont pas 10 gardes du corps
comme toi ils vont filmer je vais faire
comme le Yard moi aussi moi aussi je
suis le Jard tu vois c c'est ça que je
parle moi oui mais c'est oui mais alors
je t'adoreadore encore oui mais tu
prends encore le le le problème dans
notutre sens c'est comme voilà ça c'est
un autre c'est un autre problème ça
c'est un autre problème mais on peut
comprendre mais c'est un autre problème
merci d'avoir été là pour pour moi pour
pour résumer euh je vais vous dire moi
moi pour moi les boîtes de nuit c'est
comme partout euh moi comme je dis
souvent dans cette émission cette
émission elle est ouverte à tout le
monde euh sauf aux abrutis euh et au qu'
il y a pas voilà on distingue pas qui à
telle religion ou telle voilà c'est que
euh les cons qu'on naccepte pas dans
cette émission et euh voilà mais sinon
je pense qu'une boîte de nuit c'est
pareil voilà donc aujourd'hui voilà ce
qu'on veut c'est c'est c'est vrai que
j'espère que vous ne faites pas de
distinction parce que c'est des mecs
voilà qui sont magrébins ou des mecs
voilà ça c'est c'est le seul truc j'ai
trois salalles avec trois styles
différents et j'ai plein de clients de
toutes les origines je le dis j'ai même
une vidéo où j'en parle qui a cartonné
d'ailleurs m service que je peux vous
demander maintenant si vous pouviez
faire rentrer Daniel en discothèque ça
voilà
merci un petit service c'est pour moi
voilà ça va lui faire du bien parce que
ça fait longtemps qu' ça passe au Coué
là-dedans merci tout merci Leard merci